scream queens shoots in New Orleans
right Ola you must have a blast shooting
there yeah be a lot of fun a good summer
had the family out we rented a house
with my dad
he was doing a movie out there too so it
was family time and yeah I experienced a
lot of a lot of things yeah the eating I
would think the times that I've been in
New Orleans it is impossible I got go
lean I just named 18 pounds and really I
was drinking yeah I was drinking I
gained 18 pounds eating drinking pulling
in my egg pulled ligament my ankle and
that was that was it right so now okay
but you have to be on camera I was there
okay is there any I mean that's the
problem a lot of people can put on 18
pounds and then say alright I'm gonna
work this off but you got to be on time
I gotta be on camera you know my wife
had a suggestion for me and it was it's
actually a story that I wanted to tell
everyone and then sort of admit to the
world here but I got a Brazilian wax a
bro-zilian wax well that's what they
call it a bro Oh a bro it's the male
version of a Brazilian wax
Julien wax my wife sort of said you know
you you keep it tight down then I try to
keep it tight but she goes just just go
for it you know just just experience
what I experienced and she made an
appointment for me so wait how does that
help you yeah and that kid on more than
a couple pounds yeah well she may be put
on 18 pounds of
I've done that yeah when you're when
your belly grows you my mom's trying to
make myself just look a little bit
better you know I see yeah I did a few
manscaped down there maybe not only that
but but I was promised things you know
by my wife it was like if this happens
you know certain things might might
happen but I'm figuring you know I've
been with her for 14 years everything
that's happened down there
I thought his art already happened but
she was like if you deep you DeForest
this area there might be new
opportunities for you yes you say hey
don't leave where did you work this
place and immediately they recognized me
which was horrible so they know that I'm
about to wax my entire package off this
woman comes up to me she's about 55
years old which was nice she was like
sort of like a Navy vet or something
like that she like a cigar in her mouth
and so I was comfortable I didn't want
it to be anything but that I lie on the
little table like this she tells me to
take my pants off she leaves the room I
put a little pink towel over my my
wiener and she comes back in mm-hmm and
immediately she just grabs the town
takes it right off there was no reason
for the cheek they give you that they
give you the towel
then they want you to put it on and then
they come in and take it right off hook
it right off yeah I law they're supposed
to say tada yeah
no so then then it starts and it starts
so it's theirs okay so I figure she's
gonna be discrete you know with it with
the towel but that thing goes don't be
nervous around us Tom and I and Andy
we've all been happy Oh Lord
we've been all around world I'm like a
baby with the way his package has shown
over the years but you can't really have
much hair down there I mean you know oh
right let's yeah go ahead Sheriff well
no no I mean that you know I use it how
you doing well yeah I don't owe me a
chip my chin ah well I don't share my
Jimbo you use an electric razor down
there this is more shocking in the admit
I love murder so we heard this place and
you that's no no no no so yes so I
figured I don't know I I thought it was
gonna be 5-10 minutes but it wasn't it
took a long time because women I think
are is a little bit easier there's a lot
of parts going on right so halfway
through it was a real team effort I mean
I was pulling and make me look hot and
she was you know she's like getting
angry at me because I'm not you know
making it tight you know and Elvis came
in
Oh song for you it worked it worked it
worked out just fine they worked out you
know that's how will I do it again
maybe yeah keep us posted wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]